وفي مشهد
سينحت على جدران الذاكرة
العربية. ها هو تميم يغادر دون
القاء السلام. وبشار يقول لن
نضيع تلك الفرصة الذهبية. بينما
السعودية في الزاوية المقابلة
تعلن عن حضانة عدو بوتين الاول.
موسكو بصمت. واصحاب العيون
الضيقة يحضرون الفشار بانتظار
كلمة زيلنسكي في القمة العربية.
لماذا غادر تميم بن حمد القاعة
غاضبا? وما الذي اتى بزلنسكي
ليجلس بين حلفاء موسكو من العرب
ويتحدث بكل جرأة? هل هي خطة
خبيثة من بن سلمان? الهدف منها
اعادة الود مع امريكا ام انها
كانت خطوة غير مدروسة ستكلف
السعودية الكثير? او ربما خطط
روسية سعودية الهدف منها تعالوا
لتغادروا بخفي حنين. لتعرف اجابة
كل تلك الاسئلة. تابع الفيديو
للنهاية. مسرح المفاجآت. حتى وان
ذهبت بعض القمم في طي النسيان.
فان قمة جدة لن تلقى نفس المصير.
وربما ستظل محفورة في ذاكرة
التاريخ. فقد كانت قمة عربية
ولكنها ليست عربية بالكامل.
عديدة واخرى صادمة. لا احد يفهم
شيئا مما يحدث في جدة. في حين
وقف ولي العهد السعودي محمد بن
سلمان. كما لو كان ساحرا يكشف
الغطاء عن العديد من المفاجآت
الواحدة تلو الاخرى. امام ذهول
المشاهدين الذي لم ينقطع طوال
فترة الجلسة. ها هو بشار الاسد
يجلس على مقعد سوريا في القمة
العربية. بعد مقاطعة دامت لنحو
ثلاثة عشر عاما. وفي تلك اللحظة
كان الصيني هو الغائب الحاضر.
فعودة سوريا الاسد الى الصف
العربي لم تكن لتحدث الا لتنفيذ
بن سلمان لنصيحة الرئيس الصيني
شي جين بينغ. عندما قال له ان
عليه ان يتبع سياسة الصفر خلافات
اذا اراد للسعودي مستقبلا رائعا.
فتصالحت الرياض مع دمشق ليجلس
بشار الاسد على مقعد بلاده في
القمة العربية من جديد. ولكن
يبدو انك لن تستطيع ارضاء
الجميع. بدء كلمة الاسد في
القمة. فوجئ الجميع بامير قطر
تميم بن حمد يقف ويغادر مع وفده
القاعة ومنها الى الدوحة دون حتى
سابق انذار. لم يستغرق التصرف
القطري وقتا طويلا لتفسيره.
فالمياه الراكدة بين الدوحة
ودمشق لم تتحرك او تصفو بعد.
لدرجة ان تميم لم يتحمل الجلوس
والاستماع الى صوت الاسد ولو
للحظات قليلة. وما اكد ذلك تصريح
وزير الخارجية القطري الذي قال
فيه. ان قد تخلت عن معارضتها
لعودة سوريا للجماعة لانها لا
تريد الخروج عن الاجماع العربي.
اي ان قبول قطر لعودة سوريا لا
يعني تصفية الخلافات بينهما
لتدخل امريكا على خط الازمة
قائلة. لا نعتقد ان سوريا تستحق
العودة الى الجامعة العربية.
وهنا السؤال هل ستكون الدوحة
عائقا امام سياسة صفر خلافات
التي تتبناها الرياض حاليا يبدو
ان طريق السعودية كل خلافاتها لن
يكون مفروشا بالحرير. ضيف غريب.
كانت المفاجأة الثانية التي كشف
عنها بن سلمان الغطاء. اغرب من
ان يصدقها اي عقل. فقد فوجئ
الزعماء العرب بوجود الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي بينهم. اتيا بدعوة
من المملكة. يا الهي! ماذا يحدث?
ماذا يفعل رئيس اوكرانيا في قاعة
القمة العربية? بل قل ماذا يفعل
عدو بوتين اول في قاعة يجتمع
فيها اغلب حلفاء روسيا من العرب.
لا احد يفهم شيئا. وليت حضور
الرئيس الاوكراني كان هادئا. فقد
كان يجلس امام بشار الاسد الذي
ايد غزو روسيا لاوكرانيا علنا.
ليستغل زلينسك القمة ويقوم
باتهام العديد من الدول العربية
بالتواطؤ مع روسيا وتغاضيها عن
الهجوم الروسي لبلاده قائلا.
لسوء الحظ. هناك البعض في العالم
وهنا من بينكم من يغضون الطرف
اقفاص اسرى الحرب والضم غير
القانوني لاراض اوكرانية. انا
هنا حتى يتمكن الجميع من معرفة
ما يجري بنظرة صادقة. بغض النظر
عن مدى صعوبة محاولة الروس
التأثير فلا يزال هناك استقلالا.
ثم طالب زيلينسكي الزعماء العرب
بمساعدة شعبه وحماية الجالية
الاوكرانية المسلمة. ليزداد
الوضع توترا وحيرة بين كل
الحاضرين. كان وجود الرئيس
الاوكراني مفاجأة صادمة للجميع.
وكان اجتماع العرب ليس ناهيك عن
غرابة موقف محمد بن سلمان.
فاحتضان جدة لعدو بوتين الاول
ربما يتم فهمه على انه تحد من
السعودية لروسيا او اعلان
السعودية الحياد في الحرب
الروسية الاوكرانية او قل حرب
روسيا ضد امريكا والغرب وهذا في
احسن الاحوال. ولكن بماذا برر بن
سلمان موقفه? وهل تقبل موسكو
حياد السعودية في حربها الكبرى?
تبرير السعودية ورسالة موسكو.
وزير الخارجية السعودي الامير
فيصل بن فرحان قال مبررا دعوته
للرئيس الاوكراني. دعوتنا لفخامة
الرئيس زيلينسكي هي من باب سماع
وجهة نظر جميع الاطراف. كنا
منخرطين في فتح الحوار مع
الطرفين املا في ان نستطيع
الوصول الى سبيل يفتح الباب للحل
من خلال الحوار. يبدو ان الرياض
تريد ان تلعب دور الوسيط المحوري
لحل الازمة وانهاء الحرب. ولكن
هل سيسمح الدب الروسي للسعودية
لم يعلق بوتين على احتضان جدة
للرئيس الاوكراني. بل وارسل
برقية للقمة العربية تحدث فيها
عن الصراعات والازمات الاخرى
التي تناولها الزعماء العرب.
مؤكدا دعمه في القضية الفلسطينية
وحل الصراع في السودان. وانهاء
الازمة الليبية واليمنية وتعاونه
مع الدول العربية على اوسع نطاق.
كل هذا دون ان يتطرق الى وجود
بين العرب. ولكن هل يعني ذلك ان
بوتين سوف يتغاضى عن الرئيس
الاوكراني بين حلفاء روسيا. خطأ
فادح قد يكلف الكثير. يبدو ان
دعوة السعودية للرئيس الاوكراني
قد اغضبت الدب الروسي الذي لا
يعرف المزاح. فقد ذهب بعض
المحللين الى القول بان وجود
زلنسكي في جدة. كان خطأ فادحا
ومغامرة غير مدروسة من بن سلمان.
وانه من الواضح ان الرياض تسعى
الى زيادة دورها في الشؤون
الدولية. وكانها تريد ان تلعب
دور المنطقة. ويرى المحلل الروسي
الكسندر ان ما فعلته الرياض لم
يكن له اي داع. بل وربما يقلب
عليها الطاولة. فموسكو رغم انها
لا تحتاج الى التفاوض مع كييف.
الا انها تعاملت بشكل ايجابي مع
الوساطة السعودية. واعطت الرياض
الفرصة للتباهي بالافراج عن
المرتزقة الاجانب من فوج النازي
الاوكراني الذي كانت روسيا قد
اعتقلته سابقا. كما ان دعوة
السعودية لزلنس على انها محاولة
من اجل التملق لواشنطن وحتى تخفف
الاخيرة ضغوطها فيما يتعلق
بالتقارب السعودي الصيني وتطبيع
علاقاتها مع ايران وحتى سوريا
الاسد. لذا فان وجود سيلينسكي
على اراضي السعودية يثير الشكوك
بان تقاربها مع الصين وانهاء
حالة العداء مع ايران وسوريا
وتطبيع العلاقات معهما. كل هذا
قد لا يكون تحولا حقيقيا في
سياسة المملكة نحو استقلال اكبر
في الدولية وخروجها من عباءة
واشنطن. وانما مجرد عنصر مساومة
مع امريكا من اجل رفع قدر ومكانة
السعودية في قائمة الاولويات
الامريكية. فالدعم السعودي
والعربي لزلنسكي حتى وان كان
معنويا فقط فانه يصب في صالح
واشنطن ويجعلها تخفض من تكاليف
دعمها لكياب. وتحويل معظم هذه
التكاليف الى الدول التابعة لها.
وبهذا تصبح الرياض سببا اساسيا
في تخفيف عبء كبير عن امن
وبالتالي زيادة قوتها في مواجهة
بوتين. ويضيف المحلل الروسي
قائلا ان منح السعودية لزلنسكي
فرصة للحديث عن اراضيها. لن يخدم
دور المملكة في الوساطة بل على
العكس ربما يوقفه تماما. كما انه
لن يؤدي الى اي شيء سوى زيادة
الحرب ضراوة ومعاناة السكان
وخسارة الجميع. والان هل ترى ان
دعوة بن سلمان للزلنسكي ستقفز
بالمملكة لمركز اعلى في قائمة
الدول الكبرى؟ ام انها كانت خطأ
جسيما استفز به بوتين وستدفع
الرياض ثمنا غاليا؟